[Music]
Ukraine has been targeted by barrages of
Russian drones and missiles in recent
weeks but a multi-layered air defense
network bolstered by many Western
donations is allowing the country to
repel many of them
roughly 90 of strikes in May were
intercepted according to Ukrainian
officials
however some military analysts say
Russia is adapting its strategy
try and evade these defenses
so as attacks intensify here's how
kiev's air defense systems are working
to intercept strikes from the sky
this video shows one of dozens of aerial
bombardments taking place in Ukrainian
cities
the Russian tactic is to weaken kiev's
air defenses by exhausting their
supplies of ammunition that's according
to defense experts
how is Ukraine responding to threats
from the sky let's take a closer look
Ukraine began the war with an extensive
stockpile of soviet-era air defense
systems now they're working in tandem
with Weaponry supplied by kiev's allies
that includes the U.S supplied Patriot
and nassams and german-made gephard
the air defense systems follow a series
of steps to take down threats
that process starts with using a radar
to scan the sky for incoming attacks
then if a threat is detected the firing
system is launched so try and Blast away
the projectile the Gephart system has a
range of 3.5 Miles defense experts say
it's normally used against slower moving
targets
in this footage Ukrainian officials say
a Gephart system can be seen targeting
Russian drones
military analysts say the red dots
appear to be Tracer rounds which are
fired to create a Trail of Light towards
the target making it more visible
while systems such as the Gephart and
Nas arms can take care of low-flying
cruise missiles and drones Ukraine has
struggled to counter ballistic missiles
to Target those Ukrainian forces have
looked to the us-built Patriot two of
the systems were delivered in April in
an interview with the Wall Street
Journal Ukrainian President Vladimir
zolensky outlined its importance of
it's a patriot the sophisticated system
can detect incoming threats more than
100 miles away and it can aim and fire
at identify targets within seconds
but even when Ukraine manages to blast
missiles and drones from the sky there
are hurdles to overcome
Fallen debris can bring death and
destruction to residential areas and
remaining fragments can start fires
in addition there's been concern in Kiev
and Washington over how long dwindling
ammo stocks can last
Ukrainian president zielinski said he's
asked allies for extra support that's
his military analysts say Russia is
Shifting its strategy which could lead
to more airstrikes breaking through
Ukraine's defenses
techniques include flying drones at
night and at a lower altitude to try to
avoid radar detection
as the war continues air defense assets
could play an important role in the
counter-offensive
military analysts say Ukraine will need
to balance the air defense needs of
Civilian infrastructure with the need to
protect its troops on the front lines
so far neither side has been able to
take firm control of the Skies over
Ukraine